sur les côtes du maine les touristes
américains sont de retour et pour
plusieurs un repas est incontournable
pendant leur séjour
mais pour manger un sandwich au homard
comme celui ci il faut être prêt à payer
le prix
la guédille et ses accompagnements
seconde près de 25 dollars américains du
jamais vu affirme ce restaurateur une
hausse de prix de 25 à 30 % en deux ans
qui s'explique par plusieurs facteurs de
faibles inventaire pour débuter la
saison et les impacts de l'inflation
mais aussi l'augmentation
impressionnante de la demande créée par
la relance des activités aux états unis
selon lui en s'offrant du homard les
gens veulent se gâter plus tôt cette
année
l'enthousiaste que l'on constate dans
les restaurants et épiceries un peu
partout au pays un impact au nord de la
frontière
les etats unis sont le principal marché
d'exportation des produits de homard
canadien
le produit est international et donc le
produit va s'acheminer dans les marchés
les plus payants
cette demande aux états unis a donc un
impact à la hausse sur le prix du homard
au canada pour les pêcheurs et
transformateurs la saison 2021 débute en
force même au prix record qui son pays
dans le moment aux pêcheurs malgré la
force du dollar canadien on constate une
force rend nettement inespérée de la
demande
un particulier du marché américain
mais le bonheur des uns fait le malheur
des autres
dans le maine ces commerçants vendent
des homards vivants entier et non des
produits transformés avec des prix si
élevé certains de leurs clients
américains sont réticents à acheter
pour compenser il y a toujours les
marchés étrangers
de nombreux pays asiatiques friands de
ces homard frais ont récemment replonger
en confinement pour elle la vaccination
à l'échelle mondiale et donc la réponse
à ces ennuis
comme tant d'autres secteurs de
l'économie l'industrie du homard n'a pas
fini de naviguer en fonction des aléas
de la pandémie il si rafa lebouvier
auclair radio-canada à kennebunkport
dans le maine